la red social Twitter pensada como el
ágora digital de los debates del Siglo
21 se ha convertido en un tema de
conversación en sí misma sobre todo
Desde que la adquirió el multimillonario
elon musk quien quiso revolucionar el
funcionamiento de la plataforma en
nombre de la libertad de expresión sin
embargo bajo el nuevo propietario ha
sido recurrentes las quejas de los
usuarios que lamentan tener la página
principal llena de tuits de personas que
no siguen ni tampoco les interesa
también ha habido denuncias de la
amplificación de discursos de extrema
derecha y grandes medios de comunicación
como la cadena radial estadounidense
enviar han abandonado esta red social
vive Twitter una crisis de credibilidad
para hablar del tema nos acompaña Sergio
giraldo especialista en ciberseguridad
de safetica latinoamérica Sergio Buenos
días gracias por acompañarnos según las
estimaciones de similar web Twitter Tuvo
una disminución del 7,7% del tráfico en
marzo esto En comparación con el año
anterior y además es el tercer mes
consecutivo de caída se puede entonces
hablar de una crisis en esta plataforma
Hola Cómo estás Buenos días La verdad sí
un poco esto viene atado a un cambio de
políticas hemos evidenciado luego de la
adquisición como lo mencionabas muy bien
de los Mods
la verdad Muchos medios han abandonado
personas también lo han hecho y
específicamente se da a través del
proceso de credibilidad que se tiene
esto atado a la verificación con la que
contábamos anteriormente ahora no
sabemos De quién recibimos las noticias
no sabemos como lo mencionabas tú muy
bien Hacia dónde está enfocada la la las
noticias que recibimos entonces La
verdad sí se ha visto también
recientemente si hablamos de
ciberseguridad hemos visto también
filtraciones
que nos hacen muy a nosotros los
usuarios nos hace desconfiar mucho de la
parte de de cómo se maneja esta
información y hacia dónde empezamos a a
recibir estos mensajes y de quién es es
Es como el el Hacia dónde nos Quiero que
profundicemos en esa falta de seguridad
y en la confusión que ha habido frente a
las cuentas verificadas recordemos que
Twitter comenzó a cobrar 8 dólares para
verificar una cuenta sin embargo como
usted bien lo dice el proceso no ha sido
del todo claro por qué esta falta de
Claridad Y si esto pone en duda o no la
autoridad de Twitter
bueno Esto es una decisión que se tomó
realmente Muy pocas personas y si lo
vamos a a ver en números Muy pocas
personas están haciéndolo Muy pocas
personas también son conscientes de la
importancia de la seguridad Entonces
el cobro en sí nos va a permitir a
nosotros el poder habilitar este medio
para asegurar nuestra cuenta en sí es un
método que realmente no es tan seguro
hay muchos estudios hay muchas
digamos
posibilidades que nos están diciendo que
aunque es un método que nosotros
recomendamos no es el más seguro
Entonces aunque sí es recomendable
activarlo y anteriormente previo al al
cobro nosotros podíamos habilitarlo en
este momento nos están
de alguna manera obligando y diciéndonos
bueno quieren algo de seguridad tienen
que pagar por ella es una buena
alternativa cierto nosotros desde el
área de ciberseguridad lo recomendamos
no es el ideal
Pero dentro de lo que nosotros podemos
observar es que si tenemos la
posibilidad de hacerlo bueno está bien
las personas pueden pagar o no o en caso
contrario hay alternativas como utilizar
aplicaciones
que también nos nos aseguran nuestra
cuenta y nos pueden ayudar pues a
ofrecer esta capa de seguridad adicional
con el fin de que
evitar este tipo de filtraciones hace
muy poco una filtración del año 2021
apenas hace unos meses salió a la luz
que alrededor de 200 cuentas habían sido
como 200 millones de cuentas habían sido
comprometidas Entonces está bien que lo
hagamos pero si no lo hacemos si no
pagamos tenemos alternativas también
pues para asegurar nuestras cuentas y si
bien usted menciona que ha habido
filtraciones Desde hace dos años atrás
las polémicas han tomado fuerza desde
que elon musk se convirtió en el
propietario de esta red social y en su
ceo de hecho reporteros Sin fronteras en
un informe recientemente publicado dijo
que Mask era una amenaza para Twitter y
que amplificaba los discursos de extrema
derecha que piensa usted al respecto
Bueno ayer hay diferentes maneras de
verlo Generalmente este tipo de
plataformas pues se basan mucho en
algoritmos y bueno digamos la manera en
la que ahora está siendo dirigido pues
cambió nosotros y y hay muchas quejas
porque hay tweets que nosotros no
seguimos o hay cuentas que nosotros no
seguimos pero ese mismo pago hace que
sea
digamos que lo veamos más en nuestro
timeline y y demás Entonces es muy
importante que nosotros primero siempre
verifiquemos De dónde proviene la
información con esto que que está
pasando pues es mucho más difícil saber
si proviene de una cuenta o no válida
Entonces es importante que nosotros
primero verifiquemos siempre De dónde
proviene la información Obviamente que
si
vemos en nuestro timeline muchas
noticias que quizás no nos interese y
demás existe la posibilidad de decirle a
la misma plataforma que no nos interesa
esto puede entre comillas educar un poco
el algoritmo Y hacer que no nos
aparezcan muchas más noticias de este
tipo ni nada por el estilo Pero lo la
recomendación de siempre es siempre
verificar y seguir medios obviamente hay
algunos que en el caso por ejemplo de
France
están verificados son cuentas que
realmente
la información que proveen son es
completamente válida Entonces siempre no
basarnos ni quedarnos en en esa
información que recibimos de primera
mano por lo mismo que les indicó el el
algoritmo a veces está educado o está ya
un poco más entrenado pues para que nos
muestre todo tipo de información Sergio
pues muchas gracias por darnos también
las alternativas a todo esto y gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en 24 muchas
gracias a ustedes y un muy buen día y
nosotros seguimos con las noticias
internacionales
[Música]